what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you notice in our video on Dr Fate
explained we didn't talk about his
powers and the reason why is because I
wanted to make a separate video and then
compare the two to see how you guys
respond to it so in this video I'm going
to make you guys an expert on Dr Fate's
Powers now here's the thing there's Dr
Fate and then there's Kent Nelson and
that's a very important distinction that
we'll talk about here in a second but
one of the things to know is that when
it comes to the concept of Dr Fate this
comes from Naboo the wise who's
basically a guy part of a group called
The Lords of order who stands against a
group called The Lords of chaos now
these guys wage war against each other
all the time and the fact that they
fight is basically what maintains the
balance between good and evil in DC
Comics but they are ridiculously
powerful guys I mean they're they're
like Cosmic entities in Marvel Comics
right they're just insanely capable in
the kinds of things that they can do and
so one of the things to know is that at
some point over the course of his
existence Naboo the wise had actually
left a handful of magical artifacts that
exist on Earth so basically you have the
helmet of Fate which is one of the more
powerful artifacts that exist in DC
Comics and is actually the source of
most of Dr Fate's Powers but you also
have the Amulet of Anubis and then you
have the cloak of Destiny but the thing
about this is that while most
incarnations of Dr Fate are completely
reliant on the talismans of Naboo for
their power Kent Nelson can actually
perform some magical Feats without them
because he spent so much time training
under Naboo the wise simply put here
that he doesn't need the helmet of Fate
In order to practice magic but the magic
he practices without the helmet of Fate
is far less potent than the magic that
he can use when he does have the helmet
and so the reality here and kind of
taking a page out of our beyond omega
level video in terms of what Dr Fate's
powers are the simplest way to put this
is that he basically possesses insane
levels of magical ability due to the
helmet of faith that basically let him
do whatever it is that he wants to do
now among the more common ways that Dr
Fate uses his magic are basically by
granting himself superhuman strength and
speed flight and levitation telekinesis
and telepathy invulnerability immunity
to diseases as well as immortality kind
of because he actually did end up dying
in DC Comics at one point but Dr Fate
can also travel through time he can
create bolts of mystical energy and he
can warp matter in reality now this is
by no means an exhaustive list but it
gives you a sense of what it is that he
can do so what we're going to do is
instead of just list bombing the things
that he can do I'm actually going to
give you examples so Dr Fate is able to
manipulate matter on an atomic level
right let's focus on that for a second
that he has reassembled the atoms of a
broken construct that was created by the
original Green Lantern Alan Scott and
was able to reorganize the atoms of his
own body to make himself invisible which
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
but hey it's magic another thing that he
could do is he could actually reassemble
his own existence simply just based on a
thought that's all he needed right all
he needed was just a simple thought and
he could reconstitute his own physical
form which is insane when you think
about it but his telepathy is so
Advanced that he's actually able to
detect people and things in other
dimensions and his telekinesis was so
powerful that he was able to move a
planet into a sun which of course
destroys the entire planet itself but Dr
Fate has also demonstrated an ability to
heal the wounds and diseases of others
going so far as secure a kid of cancer
removes Suicidal Thoughts From a man's
mind and even resurrect the death Dr
fade has also been able to roll back the
borders of the entire space-time
Continuum which means that he's able to
alter the very concept of reality itself
now he's also proven himself capable of
being able to go toe-to-toe with the
Specter who's one of the strongest
beings in the entirety of the universe
and the Specter even comments that at
the height of his abilities Dr Fate was
as powerful as the Specter himself now a
little bit of an explanation here for
those of you guys who don't know who the
Specter is and the hierarchy of DC
Comics when it comes to Mystical beings
the specters at the top and in fact
depending on what era of DC Comics
you're reading the specter was basically
the hand of God's Vengeance like when
God gets pissed off that's the Specter
right that's just how powerful that guy
was he's just done a whole another
Echelon of power there's no direct
comparison from the Specter to Marvel
Comics but if we were to create one we
could call him like the Living Tribunal
so imagine a being out there that's so
powerful they can match the Living
Tribunal in power depending on the
height of their abilities and that's
what Dr Fate is in DC Comics now on
another occasion focusing on the Specter
here on another occasion when the
Specter had placed a curse on Hal Jordan
to destroy his soul Dr Fate was actually
able to reverse the spell of the Specter
and save the soul of Hal Jordan but the
fact that Dr Fate's magic is powerful
enough to defy the will of the Specter
who is probably the single most Adept
magic user in the entirety of the DC
Universe is a testament to the power of
Dr Faith but Dr Fate is also able to
exercise an enormous amount of control
over powerful Cosmic and demonic beings
he can exercise demons and was able to
banish a powerful demon back to Hell
against its will now one of the things
that I want to specify here because that
doesn't seem like overly special when it
comes to Demons in DC Comics it's a
whole different Beast from Marvel Comics
in Marvel Comics you have like Mephisto
right and you have like Damon hellstrom
and a few people like that who are
powerful beings in their own right but
in DC Comics demons are not that far
removed from God right not even that far
removed from Lucifer they're more than
enough to take on pretty much any
superhero on Earth and I think that
needs to be stated in order to give you
context otherwise it's kind of like so
like a dude who possesses people like
what's the big deal about that it is a
pretty big deal it's a pretty
significant thing now on more than one
occasion Dr Fate has been able to battle
beings of chaos and then emerge
Victorious now of course these are the
Lords of chaos these are the antithesis
the opposite of the Lords of order so
basically beings that are equal in power
to Naboo but basically evil now the
kicker about this is that it's not just
Doctor Fate per se it's not just Kent
Nelson it's actually when Kent Nelson
his wife enza who became Dr Fate at a
future point in time and then Naboo
who's the source of her power when they
all merge into a singular being but it's
basically the final form and when that
happens he becomes Godly in terms of his
power and depending on who you're
talking to in DC Comics some people will
say that Dr Fate if that level of power
actually Rivals the power of the
presence who's basically God in DC
Comics the single most powerful being in
existence kind of their version of the
one above all from Marvel Comics again
that's not an absolute I'm not saying
it's an absolute I'm just saying
depending on who you talk to some people
interpret it that way but yeah that's
the long and short of Dr Fate's Powers
now one of the things that I also want
to specify here he does have a whole
host of other abilities we're focusing
on the most powerful ones here but this
guy's gone Toe to Toe with this with
Superman like literally fought Superman
to a standstill right this guy's like
whisked the Justice League across like
Dimensions just like teleported them
away to like other dimensions this guy I
can do all kinds of crazy stuff right
this guy can fly at astronomical speeds
in the old golden age Comics back in the
1940s this guy actually traveled miles
within just fractions of a second
granted Powers were more scaled down
back then but it was still incredibly
fast even the helmet of Naboo which this
is a commonly cited point this may not
be new to you but even the helmet of
Naboo has astronomical levels of speed
the thing was able to travel to the edge
of the universe and back in a year which
is a pretty insane level of speed the
thing about this is that Dr Faye just
has your normal run-of-the-mill powers
that are granted to pretty much
everybody which are basically all the
powers of Superman minus like x-ray
vision and frost breath he just usually
has those at a higher level but then
with those talismans that He possesses
that were created and given to him by
Naboo as his chosen representative of
the Lords of order it elevates its power
to a whole different level but this begs
the question in a straight up fight
because I know people are gonna ask this
in a straight up fight who wins between
like Dr Fate and Doctor Strange I'm
gonna be honest with you guys my
personal opinion Dr Fate wins I think Dr
Fate comes out on top in a fight between
him and Doctor Strange maybe we'll do a
video where we talk about that right
where we literally have Dr Fate versus
Doctor Strange which one of these guys
is more powerful but with that being
said Guys these are basically the powers
of Dr Fate let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later peace